my goal is to be patient upon hardship
and grateful upon blessings and that I'd
be in one state or the other and so my
story is through because the pen has
been lifted and the ink has dried
Salam alaikum peace be with you
welcome to the den Shah mat your host
and my brother I'm on a sugar so Michael
how you doing I'm doing great how are
you ready how you been good to see you
again good to see you also
I'm there laughs how you feeling good
I'm good a lot
tell us tell us are you you've been
involved in the spoken word sometime
right yeah spoken word poetry the arts
something that I enjoy so I kind of
started babbling in it in my college
years I didn't even know that I could
really write until college was really
late for writers but or for some writers
and I kind of by that time I had already
developed an Islamic personality I had
you know interests in in learning and
studying Islam by then and so when I
started writing poetry it kind of just
meshed into being you know in Islamic
art form you do - kind of like bling
bling bling bling okay women are filling
or women of I feel and cars of Africa
type of thing that's the difference
what's the difference either I just post
this money's everlasting I just posted
something on the Twitter I sit down
don't get caught up with chasing the the
the after party of this life it's just
temporary it's gonna end right you got a
hangover but the real party's agenda and
that party don't stop party doesn't stop
nobody knows that and it's not even till
6:00 in the morning because there's no
day and night and that's know what her
you know a lot of times is odd for a lot
of people but what had you realize when
in what at what age at what time in your
life do you make that conscious decision
that indeed Islam was a way of life that
you wanted to live in why probably the
last year of high school so I used to go
to Sunday school just like everybody
else and you know the last two years of
high school I never used to go to Sunday
school growing up and my parents they
decided like the last two years of high
school that I'd know we have to give
this you know we have to take our kids
to Sunday school and so I went and I had
to be dragged every week to go
and then just one day I remember the you
know the brother who was teaching us is
all ahead he Allah reward him he just
started speaking about a topic that I
found fascinating which was a de Jud and
literally I just from that day on I just
consumed all of the material that I
could about that they'd done and I
became a 16 year old expert on the de
Jong at that particular time in my life
and that just transcended from from
there on to studying other things what
do you think is the I do engage with a
lot of the youth yeah what do you think
is one of the major challenges that do
you see them having nowadays I think
it's just an one of them is you know
just issue of identity like Who am I
what's my role trying to navigate being
it's not easy you're talking about
people who are growing up post 9/11
they've never really experienced the
time when Islam was not public enemy
number one or being Muslim was in public
enemy number one
and so you know trying to navigate
through that and you know when you're a
teenager when you're young you you live
and die off of acceptance from your
peers the most important group that
you're trying to please is your peer
group and your friends and so really
just figuring out your place I think is
something that's very challenging and
have lots of conversations with them
with regards to just you know where do
your pillars what are your where does
your identity come from whether I'm
talking to youth or whether I'm talking
to parents because parents also give
their children a sense of identity or
they don't give them a sense of identity
and they allow them to try to figure out
where they can get that from and we talk
about the different ways or different
sources of a person having a strong
Islamic identity what it is and what it
isn't because a lot of times what
parents end up doing when they're trying
to give their children an identity is
they're trying to give them and the
identity of being from a different
country and that doesn't work so I'm
trying to give my child a Sudanese
identity or I'm trying to give my child
a Pakistani identity or an Egyptian
identity or whatever it is and you can't
recreate that in a different country
it's not gonna work and it's not gonna
work in the u.s. but you can't give them
an Islamic identity because it's not
transcends all
borders in it it's a way of life that
you live it's not it's not restricted to
a jury got geographic place what are
your comments on many people who they
end up following the likes because we're
creatures of imitation yeah that's why
the crater sent the best of people for
us to mimic the prophets and messengers
and Muhammad peace be upon being the
last Jesus Moses Abraham in all the
preceding messengers they were the best
of role models but nowadays if
somebody's taken DJ that's their haunted
yep another we've got a Muslim name Yeah
right maybe they're taking 50 cents
yeah as role models yeah deriving their
identity from this yeah so I was I was I
was in Jamaica Queens when 50 cent came
out and he was like everybody everybody
was listening to 50 cent when he came
out we're talking about 2003 basically
it's it's very powerful it's a very
powerful current people are attracted to
strength and they're attracted to
success that's something that I think we
have to remember people aren't attracted
to losers no one wants to be no one's
attracted to cowardice and so though
when they have when young people have
strong role models to look up to when
they have leaders in their community
that are courageous like why is Malcolm
X still so attractive 50 years later
it's because he exemplifies the
personality of strength whether or not
you take the the beliefs that he had and
then Noi or what have you he still was
somebody who spoke truth to power he was
somebody who was unapologetically black
he was absolutely he was absolutely
someone who's determined to follow the
truth and he he was absolutely
courageous he was a hero and so people
until now they're so attracted to his
personality and so I think part of it is
just being strong you know if we're if
we're when people who are Muslim we
believe in Islam that we communicate
that with strength with courage or with
izi
and inshallah the added that will be
something that will inspire other people
around us now why
why why Islam why not there's so many
different religions what makes Islam the
one that you feel that people you're
following them and differentiates it
from the rest
well Islam well I believe Islam is the
truth and you know anyone who reads the
Quran I believe you know sincerely open
heart open mind that they will come to
that conclusion I've you know had
conversations with lots of people and
one of my favorite ones that I've heard
is a person he opened up the the Quran
he read the first chapter which is the
opening sort of the fat hand then he
read the next chapter and within three
or four verses he's like this is
absolutely unique why because the first
chapter the second of this the first
verses of the second chapter was called
the cow it begins with 84 I mean radical
kitab without labor fee this is the book
about which there is no doubt and so he
said I've never read a book in which the
author says there's nothing wrong with
my book at the beginning of every book
what do you find if I'm not there saying
you know if there's any shortcomings I
do apologize and you know I tried my
best and all that he said I never ever
he's like this is either the most
audacious author ever or this is beyond
human and so reading the Quran I've come
to the conclusion that this is the Word
of God that's it man with no doubt no
doubt about it that it is and it's nam
other than all of the other religions
that I've come across Islam comes with a
with a principle of falsification Islam
says hey if you don't think that Islam
is the truth this is the way for you to
prove me wrong
Allah says when consumed fill a demon as
the night I've been about to be sort of
immunity if you are in doubt with
regards to what we've revealed to our
slave you don't believe this is from God
if you don't believe that this is the
truth then you do something like it you
create a book that's like it you create
a book that has the effects that the
hold on a house you create a book that
matches the form and no one's been able
to do it it's been 1,400 years so far
that's the car on the power of the Quran
look into the crown we're gonna take a
break and we right back here on the Dean
show up in one word please subscribe to
the D show follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the link
below please also help support the D
show by making a donation in the link
below subscribe right now
[Music]
back here on the Dean show tell us what
have been some of the challenges now
with all the the rise of Islamophobia
people have a great misinformation about
Islam and Muslims have you come across
anybody I'm not getting them out there
that you've encountered that it had a
change of heart or you've had some
experience and tough questions done at
you this yeah I mean I've I've I've met
people whether it's in hotels or
neighbors or what have you and when they
find out that I'm Muslim and they're
comfortable with me and what and they
get comfortable mean then they'll be
like hey listen man I have a question
for you what's going on with Isis ELISA
what's going on with with Muslims
what's going on with Isis like because
it's so prevalent that's what they see
and so I even had yeah I had a family
recently who who basically asked me that
question and then you discuss with them
but even beyond that is just the
realization that you know what as a
Muslim I have an obligation to
communicate to people and not just
assume you know they said if the
majority of Americans have never met all
Muslims yet right they haven't met a
Muslim or they've met a Muslim and they
don't know that they've met a Muslim and
so we as Muslims we have this you know
it's very easy for us to kind of fade in
with with many of the sisters may God
bless them they're there wearing the
hijab they're wearing the uniform right
but a lot of guys they're you know
they're they fade in through through the
cracks people don't know that they're
Muslim and so I even remember recently I
was on a plane and the woman that was
sitting next to me she was she was a
professor she was a much older lady and
she was just asking me what do you do
like what are you involved in and things
like that and I was going to an Islamic
event and I'm thinking to myself in that
moment I'm on the airplane I'm thinking
to myself is this something that I
really need to share do I really need to
develop like all the details of what I'm
doing or can I just say I'm going to a
conference and just leave it at that
I thought to myself well why would I do
that and I told her exactly where I was
going what I was doing and she said to
me she was like oh
I just came back from Iran and then she
had all of this to share with me about
her experience there and you know the
conversation just we talked the entire
way there and you know this is you know
I was happy at the end of the day that
she just knew that she had met a Muslim
and that I would I had the talents that
I had and I had the challenges that I
told her I was facing and you know at
the end of the day you don't know you
know how that will affect her I know how
it affected me but I think if more
people just communicate their Islam not
not necessarily even a preaching fan
manner but just in a every day I live
amongst you manner that in Charlotte
adda it'll do something to counteract
the current of what they hear about
Islam on a day-to-day basis what did you
tell the individual who was asking about
Isis I told them that it's not
representative of Islam at all you know
it's not representative of Islam at all
the Islam that we learned and this time
that we experienced and Islam that we
all over the Muslim world that we grew
up in is one that reflects the the
virtues of the whole on being good to
your neighbor taking care of people the
prophet sallallaahu sometime he says in
a in a very authentic very clear hadith
he says that whoever kills a person who
is more add a person who you have a an
agreement with that person will not
smell the fragrance of paradise and so
when you hear about people committing
these atrocities in the United States or
in France or where have you where
they're killing their fellow citizens
that they have an agreement with the
bond of citizenship right that's beyond
what Islam allows it reminds me of a
lady she was at the airport she saw a
Muslim frame and then she thought let me
go ask him some questions and they
started talking was a Somali brother and
I think he said something on along the
lines and she also asked him about Isis
and she said he said there is Isis and
then there's people like Donald Trump
you know and then there's us in between
yeah the millions in between yeah
and there was a human connection that
was made yeah we scratch our heads you
know when we're hearing about Isis just
like I'm sure many Americans are
scratching their heads right now when
they watch the the GOP debates and
they're like what just happened what's
going on in this country of ours yeah
right so it's it's these are political
issues as opposed to issues of theology
tell us how important is it for the
human being who's out there day-to-day
working raising a family something even
just waiting to make enough money so
they can let loose on Fridays but then
they forget about the most important
question that people forget to ask
themselves what's the purpose of life
how important it is is this for a person
to really reflect where did I come from
why am I here where am I going
I mean there's a happiness or there's a
space in the heart that is not filled
except with the remembrance of God and
so no matter how much wealth a person
acquires or no matter how much success
they attain worldly success no matter
how much how many relationships that
they have there's one relationship that
their soul longs for and that's the
relationship that they have with their
Creator and so this question is a
question that you do get distracted from
you get distracted maybe add a half a
day a week a month or have you but it's
not one that anyone can afford to be
distracted for from for an entire
lifetime you have to make sure that this
question I mean we spend a couple of
years at best on earth and then we spend
thousands and thousands of years in the
grave and then beyond that is a day of
judgment and so we have to prepare for
that we have to ask you know what is the
purpose we have to seek out that purpose
even beyond there are so many people who
don't even think of these questions
anymore they're just numbed whether it's
numb by alcohol or numb by the pursuit
of happiness or numb by whatever it is
and so you have to make sure that you
ask yourself the question why am I here
what's going to happen after I die and
then begin that journey searching for
what that answer is
do you think that before we end couple
more questions there was and there's a
lot of examples of this people who are
just so famous
Williams was someone with who was a year
ago yeah happy no there was a woman he
just did a program about this Ronda
Rousey have you heard of her yeah she's
like probably the most faint was was
there's always someone knock you out
couldn't get get on that top level she
was probably the most famous most
talked-about woman because she was a MMA
fighter yeah and she suffered a loss I
think she was contemplating suicide I
didn't know that yeah she's like on top
of the world even if she suffered a loss
yeah she's still you know fame fortune
and all of that type of stuff and I mean
that's that's disheartening and it comes
from a person is balanced by knowing God
right and knowing their place and and
recognizing that when you have something
bigger that you're playing for and this
world and everything that's in it
becomes much more bearable bearable and
much more insignificant I mean every
calamity that affects a person in this
life is a seed that you plant that you
hope to to to harvest in the hereafter
if you're patient and if you recognize
the reward with a God and so this life
is not one-dimensional if a person
doesn't believe in the afterlife then
then this life becomes very difficult to
bear to some it becomes impossible to
bear but if you recognize that you know
what God is just and so there will be a
day of judgment and if I've been harmed
by anyone there will be ramifications
there will be payment there will be
justice and my goal in this life is to
worship God as as best as I can and
until I meet him and be rewarded for
what I've done
final words of encouragement for those
who might have tuned in and you know
they're struggling with a lot of the
different things that people are
struggling but now that the soul
obviously that that heart is not content
with all the material things and we got
the intention what advice would you give
for I think that one of the the greatest
things that a person can do is to call
upon God frequently to call upon him in
the morning
on him in the evening to fall upon him
whenever in whatever language a person
speaks
there's never meant for there to be any
intermediary between you and God there
is no one who can stand between you and
God and so that you reach out to him
that you call upon him and that you ask
him for guidance that you asked him for
success you know as Muslims we pray for
guidance over 17 times a day every
single one of us the best of us the most
righteous the most knowledgeable the
greatest Muslim they call upon God 17
times a day and the purpose of that is
to realize that we're not in control not
only are we not in control but all of
our goodness is really comes to us from
God and he's the one who creates us and
he's the one who takes care of us for
every minute and every second of our day
we are in need of his blessings
constantly and of his blessings as the
blessings of guidance and all of his
blessings as the blessings of happiness
and other the blessings as the blessings
of serenity and tranquility and all of
these beautiful meanings that we look
for and we seek in our day-to-day lives
and so calling upon God and speaking to
him but not just asking him but in your
heart making the commitments and saying
I am willing to submit to whatever it is
that you decide and whatever you deem to
be good for me I'm going to be willing
to submit to that because when you
recognize that God is the one who wants
the best for you and God is the one who
loves you and God is the one who will
not guide you to anything that is bad
ever when you submit to that and then
you live according to that you will live
the most beautiful life and you will
live the most happy life that any human
being can live and that is a life that
is spent in the service of God thank you
very much for being with us you heard it
here on the Dean show purpose of life
why are you here the one who loves you
who created you that's the one whose you
seek out and got some great advice from
the brother here make sure you tune in
every week to the details for more
inspiring episodes until then someone
alaikum peace be with you something I'll
subscribe right now if you haven't
already peace we got a special treat for
you he's gonna our guests that this week
is gonna perform some nice spoken word
are you ready the pen was commanded to
write everything until the day of
judgment it wrote and
Road I wrote that Adam would be created
and fashioned by the hand of God that he
would inhabit paradise and be expelled
I wrote that no one would build a ship
that would deliver him and a few of
those who believed in him from a flood
that would drown the height of mountains
it wrote of a mother in fear yet with
unbelievable courage placing her baby in
a basket and a river and that baby
growing under the watchful eye of his
maker to save his people from a
speakable horse
I wrote that David would be a king have
a son named Solomon that he would be
carried by the wind make minions of the
jinn and that he would have the kingdom
the likes that the pen would not write
for anyone after his Dominion the road
of a miraculous birth under a date palm
tree a baby speaking to his mother's
accusers his first words were and I am
the slave of God he gave me the book and
made me a prophet his name was written
Jesus the Son of Mary and that he would
be marked for death and it was written
everything that they would say after him
a road of an orphan boy who became a
shepherd who became a merchant who
became a prophet his name was Muhammad
sallallaahu suddenly me wrote the names
of his enemies I wrote the names of his
friends how blessed are they that their
names be written by his a road of the
Ummah that would come after him thought
of INSEAD entering a land that would
capture its imagination for a thousand
years
salahuddin a stone's throw away from
Jerusalem Imam Ahmed emerging from
prison the most famous man in the world
he wrote of kings and criminals the
wrote of tyrants and poets throats of
sages I wrote a wise men he wrote of
heroes it wrote incredible lows the
killing of her mother the accusation of
Aisha the sacking of Baghdad 12 million
dreams that would be shackled in ships
traversing the Atlantic where they would
be decreed to die but some dreams don't
die they transform into its melodies
that are carried on the slaves of their
transform into melodies that carry on
the lips of slaves who sing songs of
kings from one generation to the next
until freedom rings a road of
colonization and the world that would
come to be a root of the lightest love
and the heaviest sadness a root of greed
I wrote of generosity and every
in between they wrote the names of my
parents who they would be and what they
would be and all of their seeds and it
did the same for me so I neither fear
days of future loss nor cry for the
glorious past because all that is
written shall come to pass
instead my goal is to be patient upon
hardship and grateful upon blessings and
that I'd be in one state or the other
and so my story is through because the
pen has been lifted and the ink has
dried